foreign
welcome back to the devops week by
simply learn so far we have mastered the
introduction to devops Dockers and
kubernetes devops testing devops and
cloud and the important devops
development tools so far we have
finished the major fundamentals of
devops now the next important step would
be to get prepared for an interview in
today's session we will be learning the
most frequently Asked devops interview
questions so without further Ado let's
get started
so in today's live session of devops
interview questions we will be
discussing the following questions
first we will go through the get
interview questions followed by that we
will learn some Maven interview
questions Then followed by that we have
the selenium interview questions and
then we dive into Chef puppet and
ansible based interview questions and
followed by that we have Docker
interview questions then we will look
into the kubernetes interview questions
then we have nagios and finally we will
wind up this live session with Jenkins
interview questions
now I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with this
live session on devops interview
questions git is the most popular
distributed version control system used
for source code management
it helps coders to coordinate and track
their code
we have compiled the most important git
interview questions that you might face
in a git or devops interview
so without further Ado let's get started
with Git interview questions and answers
so let's just get into those source code
managements and we're going to focus
specifically on Gates the reason being
is that get is really the most popular
source code management solution right
now there are other Technologies out
there but for the types of distributed
environments that we have as source code
management with Git is probably the most
effective so the first question you'll
be asked when it comes to get is to talk
about the difference between centralized
and distributed Version Control and if
we look at the way that the two are set
up all the Technologies such as older
versions of Team Foundation server
though the current version does actually
have get in it but older versions
required a centralized server and for
you to check in and check out of code
the developer in the centralized system
does not have all the files for the
application and if the centralized
server crashes then you actually lose
all of the history of your code now in
contrast a distributed model actually we
do check in our code to a server however
for you to be effective and building out
your solution you actually check out all
of the code for the solution directly
onto your local development machine so
you can actually have a copy of the
entire solution running on your local
machine this allows you to be able to
work effectively offline it really
allows for scalability when it comes to
building out your team so if you have a
team that may be in Europe you can
actually then scale that team with
people from Asia from North America or
South America very easily and not have
to worry about whether or not they have
the right code or the wrong code and in
addition to that if the actual main
server where you're checking in your
code does crash it's not a big deal
because you actually have each person
has a copy of the code so as soon as the
server comes back up you have to check
back in and everybody's running back as
if there was nothing had happened at all
so one of the questions you'll be asked
is to give the answer to some of the
commands you use for working with Git so
if you were to be asked the question is
what is the git command that downloads
any repository from GitHub to your
computer on the screen you have four
options we have git push get Fork get
clone and get commit the answer in this
instance would be get clone now if you
want to be able to push code from your
local system to a GitHub repository
using git then first of all you want to
be able to do is connect the local
repository to a remote repository and in
the example you may want to talk about
using the command get remote ad origin
and then the actual path to a GitHub
repository you could if you wanted to
actually at this point also talk about
other repositories such as get lab that
you can also work with or a private get
repository that would be used just for
the development team once you've
actually then added the local repository
into your local computer then the second
action you want to use is a push which
is to actually push your local files out
to the master environment so you use the
command git push origin master so one
question you may be asked is what is the
difference between a bear repository and
a standard way of initializing a git
repository so let's look through what is
the standard way so the standard way
using get init allows you to create a
working directory using the command git
in it and then the folder that creates
is the folder that creates all the
revision history related to the work
that you're doing in contrast using the
bear way you have a different commands
for setting that up so it would be git
init dash dash bear and it does not
contain any working or checked out
source files locally on your machine in
addition the revision history is
actually is stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you'd have with
the normal get in its initialization so
which of the following CLI commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git RM get MV git rm-r or none of
the above well in this instance it would
be gate MV a question that you'll be
asked around commits is going to be what
is the process to revert a commit that
has already been pushed and made public
and there are two ways you can address
this the first is to actually address
the bad file in the new commit and you
can use the command git commit Dash M
and then put in a comment for why that
file is being removed the second is to
actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit ID and the commit ID and
it could be something such as
560e0938f but you'd have to find that
from the the commit that you had made
but that would allow you to revert any
bad files that you had submitted so the
two ways of being able to get files from
a git repository and you're going to be
asked to explain the difference between
git Fetch and get pull so get fetch
allows you to fetch and download only
new data from a new repository it does
not integrate any of the new data into
your working files and it can be undone
at any time if you want to break out the
remote tracking branches in contrast get
pull updates the current head Branch
with the latest changes from the remote
server so you get all of the files and
downloaded it downloads new data and
integrates it with the current working
files you have on your system and it
tries to merge remote changes with your
local ones so one of the questions
you'll get asked about get is what is a
get stash so as a developer you'll be
working on the con Branch within a
solution but what happens if you come up
with an idea where it's something that
will take a different amount of time for
you to be able to complete but you don't
want to interrupt the mainline Branch so
what you can actually do is you can
actually create a branch that allows you
to start working on your own work
outside of the mainline branch and this
is called git stash it allows you to be
able to modify your files without
interrupting the mainline Branch so you
once you start talking about branching
and get be prepared to answer and
explain the concept of branching so
essentially what it allows you to do is
have a Mainline Master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches is that allows for new features
to be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
reintroduced to the mainline Branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
Branch so on the left hand side we have
get merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating and merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is a slightly
different approach this is for projects
where you reach a point in a project
where you go okay we're going to
effectively restart the project at this
point in time and we want to ignore the
complete history that's happened before
that and that's called get rebase and
that would allow you to rewrite the
project history by creating a brand new
Mainline line branch that ignores all
other previous branches that have
happened before it you can if you want
to very quickly and easily find out all
the files that have been used to make a
particular commit so when somebody asks
you the question how do you find a list
of files that's been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command git div Dash tree dash R and
then the hash that you would use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question that you'll be asked
when you're talking about merging files
is what is a merge conflict in git and
how can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have two or
more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select changes you want to keep
in the final merge so let me go through
the steps that you would take to be able
to illustrate this when you're talking
about this particular question in your
interview now there are essentially four
stages the first would be under the
repository name you want to select a
pull request and you're going to be able
to show how that pull request would be
demonstrated inside of GitHub So within
the pull request there's going to be a
highlight of conflict markers and you'll
be a select which conflicts you want to
keep and which you want to merge and
which ones you want to change so it's a
step through how you would actually
resolve a merge conflict and the first
step would be under GitHub you want to
be able to pull the repository name and
then the pull request around that
repository in the pull request list
click the pull request with a merge
conflict and that you'd like to be able
to resolve they'll pull up a file
they'll list out all of the conflicts
for you near the bottom of that file
will be a list of the requests that need
to be resolved and then if you need to
make a decision on which branches you
want to keep or which ones you want to
change that will have to be something
you have to put in instructions inside
of the file you'll actually see that
there are conflict markers within the
instructions which are going to ask you
which files you want to change which
ones you want to keep if you have more
than one merge conflict in your file
scroll down to the next set of conflict
markers and repeat steps four and five
until you result all of the conflicts
you will want to mark your file as
resolved in GitHub so that the
repository knows that you are having
everything resolved if you have more
than one file with a conflict then you
want to go then on to the next file and
start working on those files and just
keep repeating the steps we've done up
to this point until you have all the
conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into GitHub and and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within GitHub so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use a get bash and so you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local git repository in
command line by using the CD change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected with the merge
conflict and in this instance here you
can actually see the file style guide.md
has a merge conflict in it and as before
with working with GitHub you actually go
through and you use a text editor and
use any text editor but as you go
through and edit out what you want to
keep and what you want to manage in your
conflict so you actually have a
resolution that's been created so that
you'll be able to then once you you're
using in the conflict markers you can
actually merge your files together so
that the solution itself will allow you
to incorporate your commits effectively
into the resolution once you've gone
through and applied your changes you're
able to then merge the conflicted
commits into a single commit and able to
push that up to your remote repository
welcome everyone to this topic again
which we are going to talk about that
what exactly is the different Maven
interview questions here now in this one
we are going to talk about what are the
different questions some couple of
questions we are going to go through and
we'll try to understand that what
exactly the answers are now let's talk
about the first question over here so
what exactly is in Maven here so Maven
is nothing but a kind of a popular open
tool open source build tool which is
available there now before uh Maven they
were a couple of Bill tools which was
present like and and you know a lot of
other Legacy tools was present there but
after that Maven is something which was
released as an open source tool and it
really helps the organization to uh
automate some couple of build processes
and you know have some particular
mechanisms like build publish and
deploys of of different different
projects at once itself so it's a very
powerful tool which can really help us
to do the build automations we can
integrate them with the other tools like
Jenkins and you know we can automate
them we can and schedule the belts so a
lot of various advantages we can get
with the help of this tool here it's
primary written in Java and it can be
used to build up various other kind of
projects also like c-sharp Scala Ruby
Etc so all these other typical tools can
also be built up with the help of this
tool so this tool is primedly uh used to
do the particular development and
management of the artifacts in the Java
based projects so for most of the jar
based projects nowadays this is the
default tool and it's already integrated
with the eclipse also so when you go for
a new weapon project automatically uh it
will be created for a Java project you
can use it for other languages also but
yes default choice of java of of the
Java programming language is Maven build
tool only now let's talk about next
question so what does the maven help
with so May 1 Apache Maven helps to
manage all the processes such as build
process is documentation release process
distribution deployment preparing the
artifact so all these tasks is being
primary taken care by the Apache Maven
so this tools amplifies the process of
project building it also increases the
performance of the project and the
overall building process so all these
things are something which is being
taken care by these specific Maven tool
here so it also uses the particular uh
you know it downloads the jar files of
the different dependencies for example
if your source code is dependent on some
of the Apache web service jar files or
some of the other third-party jar files
in that case you don't have to download
those jar files and keep in some
repository or keep it in some lab
directory you just have to mention that
dependency in the maven and that jar
file will be downloaded during the build
process and will be cached locally so
that's the biggest Advantage which we
get with Maven that you don't have to
take care of all these dependencies
anywhere into your Source Code system so
moving provides easy access to all the
required information it helps the
developer to build the projects and
without you know even worrying about the
dependencies processes or different
environments or different because it's
in a kind of a tool which can be used in
any platform Linux or Windows so they
don't have to do any kind of conversions
so all they have to do is that they have
to just add new dependencies and that
should be updated into the pom file and
depending on that dependencies the
source code will be built up and they
don't have to refer any kind of
third-party jar files so they don't have
to play with the class bars during the
build process so no customizations is
actually required with this one now the
next question is that what are the
different elements that Maven take case
of so there are different kind of
elements which is being taken care by
Maven so uh the these particular
parameters are elements are builds
dependencies reports distribution
releases and mailing list so these are
the typical different different elements
which is being taken care by the maven
during the build process and during the
preparation of the builds here so all
these things you can they can explore
they can extract on that part and they
can fully understand that how they can
work on all these different different
processes now next question is that what
is the difference primary difference
between the and and Maven first of all
both of them are primary used for the
Javas project so and is the older
version and Maven is something which was
launched after the ant here so and has
no formal conventions like so which can
be uh you know coded into the build.xml
file there but yes the maven has
convention so information is not
required as such in the palm.xml file
there so and is procedural whereas Maven
is declarative over here so and does not
have any kind of life cycle so it
depends on you that how you program the
and there but Maven is having a lot of
life cycles there which we can configure
we can utilize so the uh and related
scripts are not reusable because you
cannot reuse it and you have to do some
kind of customizations in order to work
on that but yeah is Maven is not having
much of the project related any kind of
dependencies they can be easily reusable
there because there is nothing about the
palm.xml file it's just the artifact
name and the dependencies which is uh
something we can override or we can
change and then the same palm.xml file
we can reuse as such for the new project
also so that is where the reusability
comes into the picture now ant is a very
specific build tool so we don't have to
there is no plugins as such which is
available there you just have to code
everything that what build process you
want to prepare whereas in case of Maven
we have the concept of plugins which can
really help us to understand that how we
can make or use of these plugins so that
we can have the reusability implemented
so these are some of the differences
which is available there between the ant
and Maven here now next thing is that
what exactly is in Palm file all about
so Palm file is nothing but its kind of
a XML file which is available there and
it's have having all the information
regarding the project and the
configuration details so it primarily
used over here that how the
configuration needs to be done and how
the setup should be performed as such
here so power.xml file is the build
script which we prepare uh you can
prepare it uh using a particular
component or you can have a particular
mechanisms or if you feel that you want
to have some kind of setup so all these
things typically can be implemented can
be done with the help of pill tools so
build tools can be really helpful for us
to do the automations and it can really
help us to understand that how some
build processes we can automate with
simply with the help of palm.xml file
here so the developers usually put up
everything inside these uh dependencies
in the XML file here so this is the file
which is uh usually present in the home
directory it's in the current directory
so that once the build is triggered it
will be picked up from the directory and
according to the steps according to the
content of the palm.x15 file the build
will be processed or will be created
here now what I'll encoded into the pump
file here so the different components
which is included into the Palm dot XML
file here is the dependencies uh
developers and contributors plugins
plugin configuration and resources so
these are the typical components which
is a part of a permodexo file which can
be a same form a lot of projects you can
do some customization and then the same
pump file can be reused for the other
projects also now one of the minimum
requirement of the elements which is
there for a palm for a palm XML file so
without which the pound XML file will
not be validated and will will be
getting a kind of validation errors so
the minimum required elements are
project root model version so it should
be 4.0.0 the group ID of the project the
artificial ID of the project and the
version of the artifact these are the
minimum things which we want to Define
so that we can understand that what kind
of artifact we are trying to prepare or
we are trying to create here so these
are the minimum required Elements which
is required in the palm.xml file without
which the validation of the pump file
will fail and the build will also fail
here
now what exactly is the mint uh with the
term called build tool so build tool is
an essential tool is a kind of a process
for building or compiling the source
code here so it's needed or it's
required for the below for generated
processes if you want to generate the
source code if you want to compile the
source code you want to generate the
source code you want to generate some
documentation from the source code you
want to compile the source code or you
want to package the source code whether
it's a jar file it's a war file or it's
a ER file so whatever the packaging mode
you want to select you will be able to
do it with the help of the particular
build tool here and if you feel that you
want to upload these particular
artifacts to the artifact tree whether
it's on remote machine or locally there
so that also you can do it with the help
of this particular build tools here so
build tools can be helpful in doing a
lot of activities for the Developers
now what are the different steps which
is involved to install Maven on Windows
now all you have to do is that you have
to just first of all download the tar
file from the maven Apache Maven
repository there once that is done so
what happens that you have to set up
some couple of environment variables now
if you download the Java jdk using the
exe file in that case the Java
underscore home will be configured
automatically but if it is not available
and you are not able to run the Java
command line in that case you have to
set up the Java underscore home and then
similarly for me when you have to go for
the maven underscore home that
particular variable you have to
configure now once that is done all you
have to do is that you have to edit the
path variable so the bin directory of
the maven extracted folder you have to
put it up into the path variable and
once that is done what will happen that
you will be able to check the latest
version the version of the maven over
there if it is like some old version
again you have to extract the latest
version and do the steps all together
again so these are some of the ways that
in which you can actually go for the
installation or the configurations of
Maven on the Windows platform
now what are the different steps which
is involved for the installation of
Maven and Ubuntu so Ubuntu it's fine you
just download the package of java GDK
there once the jdk is installed over
there what you can do you can simply go
ahead and say that yes I want to search
for a particular Maven package which is
available there so once the jdk is
installed all you have to do is that you
have to configure the Java underscore
home M3 underscore home may want to just
go home and the path variable once all
the path variables are something which
is configured then you will be able to
check the latest version like whether
it's a the version is correct or we are
getting the standard version over here
or not over here so that's the main
mechanism that how we will be able to
you know configure the maven on Ubuntu
km now what exactly is the command to
install to char into the local
repository now sometimes what happens
that we are not able to fetch like some
dependencies not present on the uh
particular Central repository memo
repository or your artificial repository
in that case you have some third party
jar which we want to install locally
onto your repository so in that case we
can go for the uh but we can download
the jar file there and then we can run
the command called mvn install install
hyphen file and then we are giving the
path like hyphen D file where the path
of the file should be provided now once
that is done so what will happen that in
the local dot M2 directory these
specific artifact will be downloaded and
will be installed here so this is a
mechanism where you will be able to
configure or you will be able to set up
the artifacts locally the Java file
locally here in the local repository so
next question is that how do you know
that the version of the maven being used
here so the version of the maven is
pretty easy to calculate so all you have
to do is that you have to just go for
mvn and space hyphen iPhone version the
moment you do that it will let you know
that what jdk or what Java version you
are using and it will also show you that
what particular Maven version your going
to use here so all that details you will
be able to get with that particular
command here
now what exactly is the clean default
and write-in variable here so these are
the build Cycles which is available
there in within Maven so these are the
built-in build Cycles so for clean what
happens that this life cycle will help
you to perform the project cleaning so
usually during the build there are some
files which is created into the target
directory so the clean life cycle is
essentially helping us to clean up all
that directory all that particular
Target directory and when we talk about
the specific default so default a
lifecycle handles the projector
deployment that is the default life
cycle and site is something which is uh
you know helpful for creating this site
documentation
you know it's kind of a life cycle which
is available there so clean default and
site other different life cycles which
can perform different different kind of
attributes or different tasks here next
question
what exactly is a maven repository so
Maven repository refers to the
directories of the package jar files
that contain metadata now the metadata
refers to the Palm files relevant to
each project so here you can able to get
your artifacts uh stored there you can
download these artifacts also during the
maven build if you put up that
dependency you will there are different
kind of repositories which is available
there one is the local repository one is
a remote repository and one is the
central repository so these are the
different typical type of repositories
which we have where we can store the
artifacts also and from where we can
download the artifacts also whenever
required now the first one is the local
repository so local repository refers to
the machine of the developers itself
where all the project related files are
stored there now whenever we work on the
uh particular Maven so there is an in
the home directory dot M2 folder is
created now usually whatever the
artifacts downloaded from artifactory or
from the maven repository it gets cached
locally there and once it is downloaded
next time it will not download the same
artifacts or the same dependency all
together again so this local repository
is something which is available locally
on the developers machine only so it
contains all the dependent jars which a
particular developer is downloading
during the maven build now remote
repositories refers to the repository
which is present on the server and uh we
from where we will be downloading the
particular dependencies so the when when
we are running the maven build on a
fresh machine so usually over there the
local repository does not exist so in
that case what happens that the dot M2
directory is empty but the moment you
run the build what will happen that the
artifacts or the dependencies will be
downloaded from the remote repository
and uh once it is done once it's
downloaded it will be added or it will
be downloaded cached locally there and
it will be uh helpful in the future run
so that will be considered as a local
Repository because all the artifacts all
the dependencies are downloaded there
and Central repository is something
which is known as the maven Community
where all the artifacts is available
there so usually we cache or we mirror
these Central repositories as our
particular remote repositories because
it could be a possibility that these
remote repositories are something which
we are hosting into our organization and
Central repository is something which is
available centrally for everyone to use
it so these are something you know some
kind of repositories where each and
every artifacts will be stored and
anyone will be able to have the access
to these uh particular artifacts here so
these artifacts are every artifices
every open source artifits is something
which is available over there to these
Central repository now how does the
maven architecture really work here so
the maven architecture really works in
the three steps the very first step is
that it reads the palm.xml file here
that's the very first step second in it
downloads the dependencies defined in
the pound or XML file into the local
repository from the central or the
remote repository here once that is done
so it will uh you know create or
generate the reports according to the
life cycles which you have configured
whether it's a clean install site deploy
package or whatever the life cycle you
want to trigger you will be triggering
that particular life cycle and
corresponding to that the build or a
specific task will be performed so these
are the three steps in which the overall
build or any kind of execution of power
XML file really happens here now what
exactly is the maven build life cycle so
Maven lifecycle isn't nothing but
collection of steps here that needs to
be uh followed for doing a proper build
of a project here so there are primary
three built-in Cycles which is available
there default which handles the project
deployment clean which handles the
project uh cleaning there and site which
handles the create version of the
project sites documentation so these are
the three primary built-in built Cycles
life cycles which is available as such
now so build life cycle has you know
different kind of phases or the stages
here because in the previous uh
particular slide we were talking about
but what are the different uh particular
build life cycles which is available
there but these are the different phases
like what are the different
step-by-steps executions like further
deep down which is available there
inside a specific Maven build life cycle
so here you can see that it's compiling
then the test compile test execution is
there then package integration test to
verify install and the lastly deploy
here so these are the different build
phases which is available as such over
here so what exactly is the command to
use to do a particular Maven side so MV
inside is something which is used to
create a maven site here now usually
whatever the artifacts is prepared that
will be prepared in the Target directory
so here also you will be able to see a
site directory which is available there
in the Target directory which you can
refer for the site documentations what
is the different conventions used while
main naming a project in May 1. so
usually it involves three components so
the full name of a project in Maven
includes first of all the group ID for
example count at Apache com dot uh
example so these are some of the uh
particular way that where you can
provide the group ID artifact ID can be
exact project name like Maven project or
whatever the project you are creating so
sample project example project so these
kind of things will be there in the
artifact ID and lastly is the version
like which version of your artifact you
want to prepare like 1.0.0 hyphen
snapshot
2.0.0 so like this information you are
providing that what particular version
you are trying to configure here now
let's move on to the intermediate level
where we will be having a little bit
more complex quotients related to the
maven here now what exactly is in Maven
artifact now usually what happens that
when we do a build process as an end of
result of the build process we will get
some artifacts for example when when we
build a dotnet project so there we will
be able to have a exe or dll files as an
artifacts similarly in case of May 1
when we do a build process there we get
the different kind of artifacts like
depending on the packaging mode like jar
file War files or the ER files here so
these are something which is you know
getting generated during the build
process during the maven process and you
can store them into your local
repository or you want to push them to
the remote repository it's something
that totally depends on you so Maven is
a tool which can help you to create all
the artifacts whether it's a jar file
whether it's a VAR files or whether it's
a ER file km
and every artifact is having three
attributes the first one is the group ID
the artifact ID and a particular version
and that's how you will be able to
identify a full-fledged artifact as such
in Maven so Maven is not about only the
name of the Char file it's actually
referring to the attributes like crop ID
the artifact ID and the version of the
artifact here now what are the different
phases of the clean life cycle here so
clean is something which is being used
to clean the target directory so that a
fresh build can be triggered there so
there are three steps pretty clean clean
and post clean here so if you wish that
you want to override the particular life
cycle configurations and you want to run
some particular steps before the clean
activity so you can do it into the
pre-clean and if you want to do it like
some steps after clean then post clean
can be utilized now what are the
different phases of the site life cycle
so pre-site site poor site and site
deploy so these are the different phases
which is available there in the site
life cycle what is exactly we meant by
the maven plugin now this is the huge
difference between the ant and Maven
here because in and we were not having
this that much support of the plugins
and that's the reason why we had to deal
with all the build configurations so we
have to Simply put the overall build
process that how the build should be
triggered but that is not something
which is there in case of Maven in May 1
we have a lot of flexibility because we
can actually put up what exactly build
configurations we want to put here we
can put some features like important
features over here in Maven and these
plugins we can utilize for example I
want to perform a compilation now I
don't really want to do any kind of
configurations in this one so what I can
do is that I can simply use the
compilation plugin in May 1 and that can
really help me because I don't have to
unnecessarily write or rewrite the
configuration that how the compilation
should be done it's something which is
pre-configured or pre-written in this
plugin is that I can simply import the
plugin and I can do the build process or
the compilation process in a pretty
standard mode so I don't really have to
do any kind of workarounds with that and
simply with a small automations I will
be able to reach that how this Maven
plugins can be integrated into my palm
or XML file and I can desire or I can
have some particular procedures and some
straps executed there so that's the
biggest benefit which we really get with
the help of Maven plugins now why
exactly the maven plugins are utilized
so to create a jar files to create the
war files to compile the code files to
perform the unit testing to create the
project documentation and to create the
project reports so there are variety of
things in which we can actually use this
Maven plugins through the Integrations
within the pound XML file there so it's
all about the plugins you just import
the plugin and that desired activity
will be performed there now what are the
different type of plugins which is there
so you can have have either build
projects for performing the build
activities you can have some build
programs for reporting plugins also
there which can be only generated or
utilized to generate the reports to
process the reports and do any kind of
formatting or any kind of processing on
the reports here so that is where the
reporting plugins are utilized now what
is exactly the difference between the
convention and the configuration in May
1. so convention is in particular
process when the developers are not
required to create the build processes
so configuration is when you know the
developers are supposed to create the
build processes so the users do not have
to rectify the configuration in detail
and once the project is created it will
automatically create a structure so they
must specify every in case of
configuration you have to provide each
and every details so that's how the
configurations really happens because
you have to put every detail into the
power XML file and that's how the
particular configurations really work as
such so this is the huge difference
between the conventions and the
configurations here now so why exactly
said that Maven uses conventions over
the configuration so maybe it pretty
much does not puts any efforts like on
the particular developers that they have
to put each and every configuration so
there are some ready-made plugins which
is available there and pretty much we
are making use of that so that in such a
case we don't have to worry about the
executions and we will be able to pretty
much work on that so conventions like
Maven uses the conventions incident of
the configurations so the developers
does no they don't just have to create
the maven project this should be doing
the configuration work and everything
should be taken care in such a way that
you just have to start the things and
rest of the things should be taken care
by the maven itself so Maven will be
responsible because the due to the
plugins it will be responsible to set up
the default architecture the default
folder structures and all you have to do
is that you have to just place the
source code in the desired folder
structure here so that's something which
you need to do as on particular
developers so what exactly is the maven
order of inheritance here so the order
of inheritance is the settings CLI
parameters parent form and the project
Palm which means that if you have some
configuration and settings that will be
the highest value then the CLI
parameters are there then the parent
Palm is there and then the project Palm
so this is the way that how the
particular parameters or the
configurations will be picked up by the
May one so that's the order so what does
the build life cycles and the phases
imply in the basic concept of Maven so
build life cycles consist of a sequence
of build phases and each build phase
consists of a sequence of goals when a
phase is run all the goals related to
that phase and its plugins are also
compiled so you will be able to have a
lot of particular goals which is
residing inside of phase there and
similarly life cycle is nothing but a
kind of a sequence of the different
phase so life cycle comes in the top
then it comes on the phases and then it
comes on the goals here now what is the
terminology called go in case of Maven
the term a terminology goal refers to
the specific task that makes it possible
for the the project to be built and
organized so it's something which we can
run so it's a actual implementation
which is going on there for example in
the build process in the live build
phase I have a different goals like
clean install package deploy these are
the different typical goals which is
available there which I can execute into
the maven here so these are the
different goals like uh which we can
execute and which we can run during a
maven build next question is what is
exactly meant by the term dependencies
and the repositories in Maven here so
dependencies refer to the Java libraries
which we usually put up into the pound
or XML file there now what happens that
sometimes our source code is requiring
some jar files like a secondary jar
files for performing the build process
so instead of downloading it and storing
it into the class path for during the
build process we just have to specify
the dependency of that artifact what
dependency we need to put and once that
dependency is put up there we will be
able to have that jar file downloaded
and cached into the local repository
during the maven build project now if
the dependencies are not present in your
local repository then Maven will try to
download it from the central repository
and again if it is not a uh you know
it's something which is available which
is downloaded from the central
repository then it will be cached
locally into the local repository so
that's a cycle which is being
implemented and utilized during this
process
now what exactly is in snapshot in Maven
so snapshot refers to the version
already available in the moment report
repository it signifies the latest
development copy that's what we do with
the case of snapshot here so Maven
checks for a new version of snapshot in
the remote repository for every new
build so during the build process like
uh you know a new snapshot version is
being downloaded and the snapshot is
updated by the data service team which
with updated source code every time to
the repository for each Maven page so
snapshot is something which we will be
using like very frequently we will be
updating to that and frequently we will
be updating the version to that and we
will try to explore and we will try to
do the modifications now what are the
different type of projects available in
Maven so there are thousands of java
projects which you know can be utilized
or we can be implemented by my one here
so this helps the as the user that they
as they no longer have to remember every
configurations to set up particular
project for example spring boot spring
MVC spring boot Etc these are the
different projects which is already
available in May 1 so most of the we
have already discussed that for the jar
based projects maybe something which is
you know considered as by default so a
lot of organizations are actually using
it for you know storing or utilizing it
for the particular Maven project now
what exactly is the maven uh archetype
over here so Maven octave refers to a
maven plugin that is uh entitled to
create a for project structure as per
its template these archives are just
project templates that are generated by
Maven when any new project is created
there so this is something which we are
using so that we will be able to create
a fresh new projects right so let's go
on to the advanced level of this Maven
questions now what exactly is the
command create a new project based on an
archive type so mvn archetype generate
is used to create a new Java Project
based on the archetype now this will
take a of some parameters from as an end
user from you and depending on that
parameters it will create the bound.xml
file it will create the source
directories inside that main Java test
all these different couple of
directories relative structures will be
automatically created now why we require
this command so that if you are going to
create a project from scratch from the
from the day one this command will help
you to have all the folder structures
created and then further on you can put
up your source code and those files as
such in this folder structure so that's
how is the mechanism that we will be
able to see that how the setup can be
performed really over here now what does
mavenclean implies now movement clean is
a plugin that suggests that it's going
to clean the files and directories there
so whenever we do a build process
usually in the Target directory we have
some class files some jar files or
whatever the generated source code which
is available that will be present in the
docker directory so the maven clean is
something which is available which is
going to clean all these directories and
why we are doing this directly structure
cleanup so that we will be able to do a
fresh uh build process and there should
not be any kind of issues as such over
here so that's the main reason why we
are looking forward for this particular
mechanism or for this particular changes
as such here now so what exactly isn't
build profile all about so build
profiles refers to the set of
configurations uh where we can have like
typically two different kind of build
processes there so if you feel that the
same palm detection file you can use you
want to run for different different uh
particular configurations so that you
will be able to do pretty much with the
help of this component so build profile
is used to do a customization processes
so that you will be able to have the
process and you will be able to perform
the configurations and the setups all
together there so that's a very
important aspect to be considered that
which we need to uh discuss when we talk
about the build profile so build profile
whenever you feel that you want to do
some customizations and you want to
proceed with the setup so that's where
it's utilized next thing is that what
are different type of build profiles
which is available there so the build
profiles can be done on for a particular
project like per project you can do you
can uh even do the build profiles in the
settings.xml file also and if you feel
that you want to do it into the global
settings.xm file so that also you can do
as such over here so there are different
ways in which you can do the
customization and once the customization
is done you will be able to have the
different uh ways of doing the setups
and the configurations over there so
what exactly is meant by the uh
particular system dependencies here so
let's talk about that also so system
dependencies refers to the particular
mechanisms where we feel that uh how the
dependencies should be you know present
there so that is something which is
having a scope of system there so these
depends senses are commonly used to help
Maven know the dependencies that is
being provided by the jdk system
dependencies are mostly used to resolve
the dependencies on the artifacts that
are provided by the jdk so these
dependencies are somewhat which is being
utilized and used over here so that we
will be able to implement and go ahead
through the system dependencies what is
the reason for using an optional
dependency here so optional dependencies
are used to decrease the transitive
burden of some libraries so what happens
that when you download an artifact when
you put up a dependency so it could be a
possibility that some dependencies as in
particular optional can also be
downloaded now these are not always
required but yes sometimes what happens
that these are downloaded so that you
don't have to put each and every uh
artifact or dependency into the pound or
XML file for example you're trying to
download some Apache tool and with that
some like three four jar files or three
four another dependencies are also
getting downloaded now if you are using
that dependencies that totally create
because you don't have to put that a
list or that entry in the dependency
list in the pound or XML file and that
can really save your time but if you
feel that you don't want to have them
and you these are the optional ones and
you really want to get rid of that so
that also you can exclude while
downloading any kind of dependency so
these are the optional ones which
depending on your requirement you can
utilize you can process and if you feel
that you don't want to get it you won't
want to process it you can simply ignore
it and you can get rid of that also now
what is the dependency scope and how
many type of dependencies scope are
there so there are different type of
dependencies course which is there which
is used on each and every stage of the
build here so compile provided runtime
test system import these are the
different kind of dependency Scopes
which we have using which we can Define
that when exactly we want to go ahead
for a specific build process so
depending on your required comment you
can explore all these build Scopes and
you can get benefits out of that what is
exactly as intransitive dependency in
May 1. so Maven avoids the need to find
out and specify libraries that our own
dependencies required by including the
transitive dependencies automatically so
transitive dependencies says that if he
depends if x depends on Y and Y depends
on Z then X depends on Y and both there
so which means that you are not
dependent on one artifact you also need
the Z artifact there with the Y artifact
so that is what you need to do so that
you will get both the dependencies there
because this is normal that if you are
trying to download some particular
artifacts or download some dependency
and that dependency is also dependent on
some other artifact or some other Char
file then you have to include both of
them so this is something which you will
be able to get so that you can easily
download all these dependent jar files
also and the maven build can be success
how can a maven build profile can be
activated so Maven build profile can be
activated through different ways so
explicitly using the command uh command
line you can talk about that which
profile you want to execute through
Maven settings you can do uh based on
environment parameters OS settings and
present and missing files so these are
the different ways in which you can
actually activate that which particular
profile you want to have so profiles
configurations can also be saved in
various situations and various files and
from there you will be able to refer
that which file you want to refer as
such now what is meant by the dependency
exclusion the exclusion is used to
exclude any transitive dependency
because you never know that if you are
trying to put up a dependency of entry
in the power X1 file that artifact is
also further dependent on another
artifact so in order to feel in order to
see that you want to exclude that
dependent artifact which is being
automatically downloaded that also we
can exclude with the help of exclusion
so you can avoid the transitive
dependency with the help of dependency
exclusions here so what exactly is in
Mojo So Mojo is nothing but Maven plane
old Java object here so it's an
executable goal in Maven and a plugin
refer to the distribution of such Moses
so Moses enable the maven to extend its
functionality that already is not
founded in so it's kind of an extension
which is there and using this we can get
some additional benefits and some
executions over there so what is the
command to create a new project based on
a hard drive so again archetype is
something which we normally use to
create the new projects now you can give
the parameters in the command itself or
you want it to in in kind of an
interactive mode where it will take the
parameters from the end user and
according to that the project will be
created onto hard drive or onto server
wherever you wish you want to create you
can create a new project
so explain about the maven settings.xml
file so Maven settings.xml file contains
the elements that are used to define
that how the maven execution should be
there so there are different uh settings
like local remote Central all these
different repositories are configured as
such over here now in this case what
happens that uh usually the
configurations are done in such a way
that it can you know go for the
executions it can go for the build
process and the complete executions can
be involved and can be achieved as a
change so all these executions are
something which we can really perform
and uh here we can put some credentials
how to connect to the remote repository
how to connect to remote repository all
that stuff is something which we talk
about over here what exactly isn't meant
by term super form here so super form
refers to the default form of Maven so
the moms of Maven can derive from so
it's nothing but a reference to a parent
form which is available there that is a
super bomb so if you define some
dependencies in that super form
automatically the uh child form will
also be able to inherit all those
dependencies so we can put some
executions like we can put some
configuration in the super pump so that
if multiple projects are going to refer
that they should be able to refer that
easily so that's the reason why we
primarily use the super pump so that we
can have the execution some processes
put up over there and all the other
projects should be effort to refer or
inherit from there so where exactly the
dependencies are stored so dependencies
are stored like in different locations
like you have the local repository
remote repository is there local
repositories on the local developers
machine and remote repository something
which is available on a server in form
of artifactory in this session we shall
make sure that you get to know about all
the important selenium interview
questions that you might be asked in
your upcoming selenium interview
selenium tester or selenium developer is
one of the most popular jobs in devops
domain according to eye data Labs a
research company which uses data to
provide industry insights found that
nearly 31 percent of software testing
tools Market belong to selenium in the
year 2018.
stats tell a lot about how preferred
selenium is all across the world
selenium skills are highly in demand as
the automation testing Market goes on
increasing professionals with these
skills are hard to find so there are
ample amount of jobs in the market for
skilled candidates companies are even
willing to go beyond the industry norms
for compensating their selenium testers
provided they have the required
certifications and experience
the median salary of selenium testers in
the UK currently falls in the range of
40 000 pounds per annum to 65 000 pounds
per annum the average salary of a
selenium automation tester in the US is
around 97 500 per annum if we talk
concerning India the average salary of
selenium tester is 19 lakhs per annum
and the salary of a selenium
professional Falls between 1 million per
annum to 4.2 million rupees per annum
this variation in salary depends on
various factors such as job location
experience education employer
certifications and many more
the salary Trends give a great idea of
what you can expect from the carrier
so now when we know at what great height
is the demand of selenium in the market
let's go on and check the top 50
selenium interview questions but before
we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our YouTube channel and
hit that Bell icon so that you can never
miss an update from Simply learn
we have divided the questions into three
parts depending on the level of
difficulty okay without further Ado
let's get started with our first part
that is the beginner level interview
questions
so the first question is what is the
main purpose of selenium
so the answer for this question is
selenium is an open source automated
testing tool used to test web
applications across various browsers
desktop and mobile apps cannot be tested
using selenium however other tools like
hp's qtp and Appian can be used to test
software and mobile applications
it is a cloud-based testing platform
that allows testers to record their
actions and Export them selenium enables
parallel test execution which increases
the efficiency of tests
selenium can test web applications
against browsers like Firefox Opera
Chrome and Safari to name a few the test
code can be written in various
programming languages like Java Perl
Python and PHP selenium is platform
independent and can be deployed on a
different operating systems like Windows
Linux and Macintosh
selenium can be integrated with
third-party software tools like junit
and test NG for test management
selenium is not just a single tool but a
suit of software each with different
approach to support automation testing
it comprises of four major components
which include selenium integrated
development Enterprise selenium remote
control now deprecated web driver and
finally selenium grid now moving on to
the next question
what do you understand by automation
testing automation testing uses
automation tools to write and execute
test cases
in this case no manual involvement is
needed for executing an automated test
suit testers prefer automation tools to
write test scripts and test cases and
then group them into test suits
automation testing enables the use of
specialized tools to automate the
execution of manually designed test
cases without any human intervention
automation testing tools may access the
test data control the execution of tests
and compare the actual result against
the expected result and finally
generating detailed test reports of the
system under test
now the third question is what are the
advantages of automation testing this is
one of the most asked interview
questions in any automation testing job
some of the advantages of automation
testing are the tool supports both
performance and functional testing it
supports the execution of parallel test
cases it enables parallel execution in
the combination of different operating
systems and browser environments there
is minimal manual intervention and test
scripts can be run unattended this
reduces the chances of human errors
there is reusability of code that is
create one time and execute multiple
times with less or no maintenance
automation testing saves time and money
and is faster in execution
in automation testing there are easy
reporting which means it generates
automatic reports after execution
it is easy for compatibility testing and
is cheaper compared to manual testing in
the long run
automated testing is more reliable more
powerful and versatile automation tools
allow us to integrate with cross browser
testing tools Jenkins GitHub Etc it is
mostly used for regression testing and
supports execution of repeated test
cases
now moving on to the fourth question
what is the difference between selenium
2.0 and selenium 3.0
selenium 2 is nothing but integration of
Webdriver with selenium RC or selenium
one
selenium 1 is a well-established
framework that supports various browsers
due to its JavaScript implementation
the strengths of both the selenium
Webdriver and selenium 1 are combined in
selenium tube
which makes it obvious that the
drawbacks were earlier there will no
longer be there in 2.0 on the other hand
in the case of selenium 3.0 selenium 3.0
can be referred to as an extended
version of selenium 2.0 solving bugs and
increasing stability the big chance in
the selenium 3.0 is the core being
replaced by back-end web driver it won't
be wrong to say that selenium 3 would be
majorly be the choice of software
testing tool for both web and mobile
based applications now moving ahead on
to the fifth question
what are the testing types supported by
selenium so the answer for this question
is testing types that can be supported
by selenium are as follows functional
testing regression testing
re-testing acceptance testing end-to-end
testing smoke testing sanity testing
responsive testing cross browser testing
UI testing integration testing and many
more
moving on to the next question
what are the different selenium suit
components so the answer for this
question is there are four components in
selenium suit first is the selenium
remote control or selenium RC selenium
remote control enables the writing of
automated web applications in languages
such as Java c-sharp Etc
it is hardly in use today as the
Webdriver offers more powerful
functionalities the second is the
selenium grid selenium grid enables the
running of tests in parallel on several
machines the commands are routed to the
remote web browser instances and one
server acts as the Hub The Hub is
responsible for conducting several tests
on multiple machines
the third is the selenium IDE selenium
IDE needs no additional setup except
installing the extension on your browser
the IDE makes the test debugging easier
with features like setting breakpoints
and pausing exceptions and the last and
the fourth tool in the suit is selenium
web driver selenium Webdriver is the
most critical component of the selenium
tool suit that allows cross browser
compatibility testing the Webdriver
supports various operating systems like
Windows Mac Linux Unix Etc
now let's go on further and check the
next question what are the different
programming languages browsers and
operating systems supported by selenium
so the answer for this question is
selenium supports various programming
languages to write test code with
language specific drivers that offer
commands from the selenium API the
common language is used by testers to
write selenium code are C sharp Java
Perl PHP Python and Ruby
Java is the favorite language for use
with a selenium 1 and 2 but the ease of
using Python and Ruby has led to many
testers opting for these languages as
well
so moving on to the next part of the
question which deals with the browsers
supported by selenium
the main reason for selenium's
popularity is the wide and comprehensive
list of features available on the
platform with selenium test execution
remains seamless on just about all
available web browsers to name a few we
have Google Chrome Mozilla Firefox
Internet Explorer Opera Safari and Edge
so now let's talk with respect to
operating systems that could be
integrated with selenium selenium
enables creating and testing suits on
any platform and executing their test
cases on different one
for example the tester could write test
cases using Windows operating system and
then run them on a Linux based operating
system so to name a few selenium can
support Android iOS Windows Linux Mac
and Solaris
now let's go on and see the next
question what are the advantages of
Webdriver over selenium RC so the answer
for this question is Webdriver is faster
in comparison to selenium RC because of
its simple architecture the Webdriver
can directly communicate to the browser
while selenium RC needs the RC servers
to help to do so
Webdriver API is more concise than
selenium RC and can support HTML unit
while selenium RC cannot
selenium Webdriver tool is used for
automating web application testing to
verify that it works as expected or not
it mainly supports browsers like Firefox
Chrome Safari and Internet Explorer
it also permits you to execute cross
browser testing the next question here
is why testers choose selenium over qtp
so the answer for this question is
selenium is an open source tool and it
is specifically designed to test
web-based applications in selenium we
can execute tests when a browser is
minimized whereas in qtp we need to have
an application under test to be visible
on the desktop and selenium multiple
cases can be executed in parallel unlike
UDP where we can execute only one test
at a time
there are several browsers supported by
selenium while qtp just supports
internet explorers on Windows
selenium supports mobile devices like
Android iPhone Blackberry headless
webkit whereas on the other hand qtp
uses a commercial product for mobile app
test automation that is HP UFT mobile
selenium supports different programming
languages while qdb supports only Visual
Basic script and also selenium has zero
maintenance cost as it is open source
whereas qtp has a license and annual
maintenance charges
so now these were the few reasons why
testers mainly choose selenium over qtp
now moving ahead into our next question
what is the use of XPath
so the answer for this question is XPath
is a selenium technique used to navigate
through the HTML structure of a web page
it uses a non-xml syntax to provide a
way of pointing to different parts of an
XML document
it can also be used to test address
nodes within a document to determine
whether the match a pattern or not while
other locators in selenium that search
for elements using tags or css class
names are simpler to use they may not be
sufficient to select old om elements of
the HTML document
the primary purpose of XPath is to
address parts of the XML document now
moving on to the next question how can
you locate a web element in selenium so
the answer is selenium uses locators to
locate and identify web elements there
are different types of locators in
selenium some of the locators are
mentioned here
the first type of expat locator is the
ID the best and the most popular method
to identify web elements is to use ID
and obviously each element's ID is
definitely unique the second type is the
class name in this case the class name
of the element is used to find the
element the third type is the link test
where the text of the link is used to
find the element all the hyperlinks on a
web page can be identified using link
text the links on the web page can be
determined with the help of anchor tag
the anchor tag is used to create the
hyperlinks on the web page and the text
between the opening and closing of
anchor tags constitutes the link text
then comes the expat locator that uses
the name of the element to find that
particular element the other type of
expat locator is the XPath this required
to find the dynamic element and to
Traverse between different elements of
the web page the last type of expat
locator is the CSS path it locates the
elements to have no class name or ID now
moving ahead into the next question name
the different types of Webdriver apis
so the answer for this question is the
Webdriver API refers to the standard
that abstracts out the device or
browser-specific bindings from the
developer so that the test script can be
written in any programming language and
run on many different browsers via a web
driver
the different types of Webdriver API in
selenium are Android driver Chrome
driver event firing web driver Firefox
driver HTML unit driver Internet
Explorer driver iPhone Driver iPhone
simulator driver remote web driver
now moving ahead into the next question
what does a slash signify in XPath and
what is the difference between single
and double slash the answer for this
question is the expat syntaxes are path
Expressions that are used for addressing
into a document slashes are used to
create XPath with an absolute or
relative path XPath uses path
Expressions to select nodes in an XML
document there are two cases one is the
single slash where the other is the
double slash single slash creates XPath
with an absolute path which means that
the X path would be made to begin
selecting from the start node double
slash on the other hand creates XPath
with a relative path which means that
XPath would be made to begin selecting
from anywhere in the document now moving
on to the next question
explain absolute XPath and relativex
path so the answer for this question is
absolute XPath starts from the root node
and ends at the desired descendant
elements node
it starts with the top HTML node and
ends with the input node it starts with
a single forward slash
as we discussed in the previous question
while on the other hand the relativex
path begins from the middle of the HTML
Dom structure relativex part starts from
any node in between the HTML page and
the current elements node and it starts
with a double forward slash
then the other point of consideration is
the difference in the drawback and the
case of absolute XPath is that if there
are any chances in the elements path
then XPath will fail and in the case of
relativex path it enables writing from
the middle of the HTML Dom structure
without any need to write the long X
path
we can see the syntax of the two
absolute XPath and relativex path on
screen and we can notice the difference
in the slashes in case of both of them
now moving on to the next question name
some automation tools that can be
integrated with selenium to achieve
continuous testing
selenium can be integrated with several
automation tools some of them are Maven
Jenkins Docker test NG junit iPhone
Driver iPhone simulator driver remote
web driver
now moving on to the next question
differentiate between verify and asset
commands
assets and verify methods are commonly
used in selenium for verifying or
validating applications if the asset
condition is true then the program
control will execute the next step but
if the condition is false then the
execution will stop and further test
steps will not be executed whereas in
the verifying condition there won't be
any pause in the test execution even
though the verify condition is true or
false there are two different types of
assets the hard asset and the soft asset
while there are no categories in case of
verification the hard asset condition
throws an exception immediately after
the asset fails and carries out over the
next case of the suit on the other hand
while the soft asset condition does not
throw an exception immediately when the
assertion fails collects them and
carries out with the next validation
now moving on to the next question what
are the different types of junit
annotations which are used in selenium
junit annotation is a special form of
syntactic metadata that could be added
to Java source code for better code
readability and structure annotations
were introduced in junit 4 which makes
the Java code more readable and simple
the different types of junit annotations
are test before after before class after
class ignore run with
now the next question in the docket is
how is test NG better than junit
test NG and junit are both open source
Frameworks supported by selenium
Webdriver
test NG is a testing framework based on
junit and N unit to simplify a broad
range of testing needs from unit testing
to integration testing there are more
functionalities added to test NGE which
makes it more powerful than junit test
NG enables dependency testing which
isn't there in junit now moving on to
the next question what are the different
types of selenium Frameworks
the selenium framework is what makes
code maintenance easy and efficient with
our Frameworks users might place the
code and data simultaneously which is
neither reusable nor readable there are
beneficial outcomes or Frameworks like
increased code reusability higher
portability reduce script maintenance
cost better code readability and many
more
there are three types of Frameworks
created by selenium Webdriver to
automate manual test cases the first
type is data driven the data driven
framework in selenium refers to the
method of separating data sets from the
test case then the second framework is
the keyword driven framework this
framework is a method used for speeding
up automated testing by separating
keywords for common sets of functions
and instructions then the third
framework is the hybrid framework where
we utilize the advantages of both the
keyword driven framework as well as data
driven framework now let's move on to
the next question
what is data driven and keyword driven
data driven framework is based on
several data sets generated in external
file and then import it to the
automation testing tool hence test data
is generated from external files like
Excel CSV or XML the data sets are
separate from the original script from
which the required input may be fetched
let's check on what is keyword driven
framework now the idea behind the
keyword driven approach in automation is
to separate the coding from the test
case and test step this helps a
non-technical person to understand the
automation very well
the instructions required to perform the
operation are written in an external
file like Excel sheet which keeps most
of the data and keyword driven which is
needed for the test like test case test
steps
test objects and actions the
functionalities to be tested can be
easily controlled by the users so this
was all about The Beginner's level of
interview questions now let's go on
further and check some intermediate
level of interview questions that might
help you take a step further in your
preparation now the 21st question is
what is selenium Webdriver so the answer
for this question is selenium Webdriver
is the most important component of the
selenium tool suit the web driver allows
cross browser compatibility testing and
supports various operating systems like
Windows Mac Linux Unix and Etc
it also provides compatibility with a
range of languages including python Java
Perl Ruby Etc the Webdriver provides
support for many different browsers like
Chrome Firefox Opera Etc and provides
faster execution
of the test scripts compared to other
tools the next question is what is the
need of selenium Webdriver so the answer
for this question is
selenium Webdriver provides a very
user-friendly interface that could be
easily understood Webdriver is a
programming interface that helps create
and run test cases it makes provision to
act on web elements the web driver has
many other features in comparison to
selenium RC and selenium IDE now moving
on to the next question
how is the selenium Webdriver different
from selenium RC and selenium IDE
Al Webdriver is an open source
collection of apis which is used to test
web applications the selenium Webdriver
tool is used for automating web
application testing to verify that it
works as expected or not
unlike the selenium IDE selenium
Webdriver can work with many different
browsers then the web driver does not
require the user to start the server as
in case of selenium RC
selenium Webdriver is an API and not a
graphical user interface based Plugin or
a standalone Java application
in selenium Webdriver all the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature
unlike the other tool in addition to
that selenium Webdriver supports
listeners otherwise was implementation
is not supported the Webdriver also
supports IOS and Android testing which
is not supported by RC and IDE now let's
move on to the next question
what is the architecture of selenium
Webdriver
selenium Webdriver architecture in a
simplified diagram is shown on the
screen
selenium Webdriver API enables
interaction between browsers and browser
drivers
this architecture consists of four
layers namely the selenium language
bindings Json via protocol browser
drivers and real drivers
selenium language bindings consists of
languages like Java Ruby Python c-sharp
and so on after the test cases are
triggered entire selenium code will be
converted to Json format
Json stands for JavaScript object
notation
it takes up the task of transferring
information from the server to the
client Json wire protocol is primarily
responsible for the transfer of data
between HTTP servers generated Json is
made available to browser drivers
through HTTP protocol
each browser has a specific browser
driver browser drivers interact with
their respective browsers and execute
the commands by interpreting Json
received from the browser
as soon as the browser driver gets any
instructions they run them on the real
driver or browsers the response is given
back in the form of the HTTP response
moving forward to the next question that
is the 25th question
what are the drawbacks of selenium
Webdriver
selenium Webdriver does not support
testing for desktop applications it
requires the expertise of team and
resources to manage no inbuilt reporting
capability test reports are generated
with the help of plugins like junit and
test NG and also requires a lot of
Maintenance and it is difficult to scale
if you want to get the technical issues
resolved one must trust the community
forums in selenium Webdriver testing of
images is not possible for testing of
images integration of selenium with
sickly is needed
the next question is how does selenium
grid works so the answer for this
question is
selenium grid is a smart proxy server
that makes it easy to run tests in
parallel on multiple machines
this is done by routing commands to
remote web browser instances where one
server acts as the Hub The Hub is
responsible for conducting several tests
on multiple machines
now moving on to the next question what
are some of the common exceptions in
selenium Webdriver the answer is
automation code execution usually may
not carry out as expected due to many
factors involved in execution such as
Network stability issues internet issues
server stability Etc we might get
exceptions due to insufficient waiting
time or incorrect syntaxes parameters
Etc some of the most common exceptions
are no such element exception no windows
exception no such frames exception no
alert present exception invalid selector
exception element not visible exception
element not selectable exception timeout
exception no such session exception
now moving on to the next question what
is the difference between type and type
into weight command
so the answer for this question is
the two commands type and type and
weight command have their own specific
purpose the purpose of type command is
to type keyboard key values in the text
box the command can be used to select
the value of combo box whereas the type
and weight command is used when the
typing is completed and the web page
starts loading the command waits for the
software application page to reload now
the next question
what is the difference between find
element and find elements in selenium
here the find element command is used to
identify a web element within a web page
it Returns the first web element that
matches the search in case there are
multiple elements and throws an
exception called No Such elements
exception if the element is not found
whereas the find elements command is
used to identify a list of web elements
within a page it Returns the list of
elements that match more than one
element and does not throw an exception
but returns an empty list if there are
no matching elements now moving on to
the next question what is meant by
weight in selenium how many types of
Weights are there in selenium
the weight functions are very essential
when it comes to executing selenium
tests
they help in observing and
troubleshooting the issues that may
occur due to variation in long time
in automation testing weight commands
direct the test execution to pause for a
certain length of time before moving on
to the next step there are two types of
Fate commands they are the implicit
weight and the explicit weight first we
will learn the implicit weight implicit
weights tell the web driver to wait for
a certain amount of time before it
throws an exception once we set the time
Webdriver will wait for the element
based on the time we said before it
throws an exception the default setting
is zero we need to set some wait time to
make a web driver to wait for a required
time
now we will learn about the explicit
weight the explicit to weight in
selenium is used to tell the web driver
to wait for a certain condition or
maximum time exceeded before throwing an
exception that as the element not
visible exception
moving on to the next question
what is the biggest disadvantage of
implicit weight
the main disadvantage of the implicit
weight is that it slows down the test
performance Webdriver will wait for some
specific amount of time before it throws
an exception for example if you set the
waiting time to be 10 seconds and the
elements appear in the Dom in 11 seconds
your test will fail because you told to
wait for a maximum of 10 seconds only
now moving on to the next question what
are the type of navigation commands
so the different types of navigation
commands are the first one driver dot
navigate to URL this navigates to the
provided URL
then comes
driver.navigate.refresh this method
refreshes the current page the third
command is the driver.navigate dot
forward this method does the same
operation as clicking on forward button
of any browser it neither accepts nor
returns anything
last navigation command is the
driver.navigate dot pack this method
does the same operation as clicking on
the back button of any browser it
neither accepts nor returns anything
moving on to the next question
what is meant by same origin policy and
how is it handled
same origin policy is a feature taken
for security purposes
according to this policy a web browser
enables the access of scripts from one
web page to the other if both the pages
have the same origin the origin policy
protects a malicious script on one page
to access sensitive data on another
followed by this we have the next
question what is selenase and how is it
classified selenis is a set of selenium
commands which are used to test your web
application testers can test the broken
links the existence of some objects on
the UI Ajax functionality alerts on
window list options and a lot more using
selenis selenium commands tells the
selenium automation engine to perform
certain tasks selenase can be classified
into a set of three types of commands
which are action accessors and
assertions moving ahead we have the 35th
question what is the difference between
driver.close method and Driver dot quit
method so the answer for this question
is the driver.close command is used to
close the current browser window if
there are multiple windows open on the
screen then the one on Focus will be
closed whereas the driver dot quit
command has is also used for the same
purpose if there are multiple browser
windows open on the screen then the
command closes all of them at once
moving ahead we have the advanced level
of interview questions now we are done
with the intermediate level of selenium
interview questions let's now buckle up
a little more and learn the advanced
level of interview questions the first
question in this category is how do you
type text in an input box using selenium
the method used to type text in input
boxes is send Keys the send Keys method
allows typing automatically into an
editable field during the execution of
any tests these fields are web elements
that can be identified using locators
like element ID name class name Etc now
moving on to the next question how to
click on a hyperlink in selenium the
command used to click on the hyperlink
uses link text to find the element the
command finds the element using link
text and then clicks on the element
whereafter the user would be redirected
to the corresponding page you can find
the syntax of the command on the screen
moving on to the next question how to
scroll down a page using JavaScript
the method used to scroll down to a page
is scroll by we can see the syntaxis of
a set of commands the first syntax that
is the execute script here is the
general Syntax for scroll by command
then the second syntax of JavaScript
executor is create a JavaScript object
then the third syntax driver.get is the
syntax of launching the desired
application then the last syntax that is
the js.execute script is for the scroll
down to the desired location moving
forward we have the next question what
is the way of typing in a text box
without using send Keys the text can be
entered into a text box by using
JavaScript executor the commands that
could be used for the process can be
seen on the screen you can use
JavaScript executor and jse Dot execute
script for the work to be done now
moving forward we have the next question
how how to select a value from a drop
down in selenium Webdriver
for selecting and deselecting from a
drop down in selenium Webdriver select
class as used the objects of Select type
can be initialized by passing the drop
down web element as a parameter to its
Constructor the syntax of the commands
can be seen on the screen the web
element test drop command and the
command to select the drop down here the
Webdriver offers three ways to select
from a drop down box the first way is to
select a buy index that is the selection
is based on index starting from 0 then
comes select by value that is selection
based on value the last way is Select by
visual text that is selection of option
that displays text matching the given
argument the next question is what is
the use of switch to command the answer
for this question is the switch to
command is used to switch between
Windows frames or pop-ups within the app
application every window instantiated by
the Webdriver is given a unique
alphanumeric value called window handle
we can see the syntax of commands on the
screen
the First Command that is the string
handle command is used to get the window
handle of the window you wish to switch
to and then the driver dot switch to
command is used to switch to the desired
window
this question is what is meant by object
repository in selenium Webdriver an
object repository is a common storage
location for all objects if we talk in
the context of selenium Webdriver these
objects would typically be the locators
used to identify web elements uniquely
for example if there is a chance in one
web elements locator value then only the
object repository has to be changed
instead of all the test cases the object
respositories have to be built in
selenium Webdriver using the key value
pair approach the two types of object
respositories may be created in selenium
Webdriver are the first one object
expository using properties file and the
next one object expository in XML moving
ahead we have the 43rd question how to
upload a file in selenium Webdriver
to upload a file in selenium Webdriver
the send keys are robot class method are
used the initial step is to First locate
the text box and then set the file path
using send Keys method and click on
submit the Syntax for the command can be
seen on the screen
the first syntax of the web element
command is used to locate the browse
button then the second syntax of the
browse dot send Keys is used to pass the
file path to be uploaded using send Keys
method moving on to the next question
what is the way to set browser window
size in selenium so the answer for this
question is the window size can be
maximized set or resized to maximize the
window we use the
driver.manage.window.maximize method or
command and then to set the window size
we can use Dimension D is equals to new
dimension wherein the brackets we give
the dimensions we want to set the size
now moving on to the next question how
can you debug test and selenium IDE the
steps to debug the test and selenium IDE
are the first step is to insert a
breakpoint from the place you want to
execute your test then execute the text
case after the test case has started
executing the execution will pause at
the breakpoint then click on the blue
button with the next statement to
continue and finally click on the Run
button to execute all the commands
moving ahead we have the next question
how to insert a breakpoint in selenium
IDE the steps to insert a breakpoint in
selenium Ider the first step is to go
into the selenium IDE right click on the
command and select toggle breakpoint
then select the command and press the b
key on the keyboard post that to clear
the breakpoint Press B key again
and multiple breakpoints can be set up
in the selenium IDE moving forward we
have the next question what is a pause
on an exception in selenium IDE so the
answer for this question is the pause on
an exception as a feature that is used
to handle exceptions in selenium IDE the
feature can be used by clicking on the
pause button on the right top corner of
the IDE window the execution stops when
an exception is encountered and the
script enters to the debug mode so the
entire test does not fail and the error
can be resolved
moving forward we have the 48th question
what can result in the failure of
selenium IDE
so the answer for this question is
selenium IDE is one of the most
accessible record and play tools in the
selenium tool suit which requires no
particular setup the selenium IDE comes
with a very rich set of commands powered
by sirness and allows us to record and
test different web application
interactions with the browser but then
there are certain times when the
selenium ID might fail some of those
instances are when selenium cannot
locate the element if the locator has
changed then one more such instance is
when the element to be accessed cannot
be found on the web page and operation
as timed out and one more case is when
the element being tried to access is not
created
for finding if the link is broken are
working fine we use the driver.get
method when we use driver.getmethod to
navigate to a URL it will respond with a
status of 200 OK 200 OK denotes that the
link is working and it has been obtained
if any other status is obtained then it
indicates that the link is broken some
of the HTTP status codes are 200 that
indicates it's a valid link 404
indicates link not found 400 indicates
bad request 401 indicates
unauthorized and finally 500 that
indicates internal error and now we are
at the last question
how to log into any site if it is
showing an authentication pop-up for
username and password so the answer for
this question is to handle
authentication pop-ups we need to verify
its appearance and then handle them
using an explicit weight command the
syntax of the explicit weight command to
be used is on the screen that is
the first syntax Webdriver weight syntax
the second syntax is the alert alert
equals to weight dot until refers to the
use of alert class to verify the alert
and the last syntax is alert dot
authenticate that is there to provide
the credentials after the verification
in the previous step welcome to this
video on the interviewee questions of
configuration management tools chef
ansible and puppet
Chef is a configuration management tool
written in Ruby underline which provides
continuous deployment increases system
robustness and provides Cloud
integration
ansible is another open source software
tool for provisioning configuration
management and application deployment
and puppet is a configuration management
tool that can also be used as a
deployment tool and implements
infrastructure as a code
in this video we have compiled the most
important interview questions of
configuration management tools chef
ansible and puppet that you might face
in a devops interview
so without further Ado let's get started
so let's just get into the first section
which configuration management so one of
the questions that you'll get asked
right away is why do you have SSL
certificates used for Chef really
fundamentally your immediate answer
should be security SSL provides for a
very high level of private security and
private and public key pairing this
really is essential to ensure that you
have a secure environment throughout
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using SSL and
you're using the private public key
model within SSL you're able to
guarantee the systems on your network
that the chef that you'll be able to
validate that the nodes within your
network the chef is validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters so you will also be asked
some questions such as the following
which is the following commands would
you use to stop or disable the HTTP
service when the system boots and you'll
typically get four responses and
there'll be hashtag systemctl disable
httpd.service or is it system disable
http.service system disable httpd or the
final option which is systemctl disable
httpd dot service your answer should be
the first one which is hashtag systemctl
disable
http.service so Chef comes with a series
of tools that allow it to function
effectively and one of the tools that
you're going to be asked about is what
is Test Kitchen and Test Kitchen is
essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to test out your
cookbook before you actually deploy it
to a real node so some of the commands
that you would use are for instance if
you want to create an instance of Test
Kitchen you would do kitchen create if
you want to destroy an instance after
you've created it you do kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances you would do kitchen
converge so a question you'll get is
around Chef is how does Chef apply
differ from Chef client now so
fundamentally the difference between
them is that Chef apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas Chef client looks to apply and
validate the entire cookbook that's run
in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focus on the entire cookbook so there
are some differences when you're working
with different command lines so for
instance when you're working with a
puppets and you're working with one
version of puppets and you want to do
what is the command to sign a requested
certificate the top example here is for
puppet version 2.7 whereas the lower
option here is for puppet version three
now that's something to bear in mind
when you're going through your interview
process is that the tools that are used
within a continuous integration can
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show you the Deep
knowledge that you have which open
source or Community tools do you use to
make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
Foundation of puppet itself and so the
three options you have is being able to
track configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's been done with puppet
our Version Control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through Jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira Git and Jenkins so
what are the resources in public well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic units of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppets one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class and puppets and so a
class and puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this can
include Services files and packages and
we have on the screen here example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
and particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable file files and
templates embedded with inside of the
Playbook so the example we have here on
the screen actually shows you one role
within a Playbook and in this role it is
to install Tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as French
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to ask is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within ansible and really
the answer comes down to two things one
is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have Foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of Foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another file in your playbook
the second is to import an improvement
of an include which ensures that a file
is added only once and then the third is
rows to manage the tasks within the
Playbook so a question you will be asked
is provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agentless installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for Windows in contrast puppet is an
agent based installation it's written in
Ruby the configuration files are written
in DSL and it has support on all pop
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture ansible it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture Docker is a popular
devops tool used to automate the
deployment of applications in
lightweight containers so that
applications can work efficiently in
different environments
Docker was initially released in 2013
and since then has become the go-to
solution for containerization
in this video we have compiled the most
important Docker interview questions
that you might face in a Docker or
devops interview
so without further Ado let's get started
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of Docker is and Docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so Docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker Daemon which is run as a rest API
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute Docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of Docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a Docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for Docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all Docker does contain an occupy Docker
containers occupy significantly less
space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
Docker is significantly faster than a VM
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single Docker image Docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation Docker data volumes can
be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your Arguments for Docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for Docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like Docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
Docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is Leverage The Power of
Docker swarm so darker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed so what are the
commands to create a Docker swarm and so
here we have an example of what a
manager node would look like and once
you've created a swarm on your major
node you can now add working nodes to
that swarm and again when you're
stepping through this process be very
precise in the execution part that needs
to be taken to be able to effectively
create a swarm so start with manager
node and then you create a worker node
and then finally when a node is
initialized as a manager note it can
immediately create a token and that
token is used for the worker nodes and
associating the IP address with the
worker nodes question 17 how to run
multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers as a single service by using
Docker compose and Docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a Docker file so a
Docker file actually is used for
creating Docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can I
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things I really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
Whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the Whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as in architect this
should be something that you're
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a Docker file so we go through
and we have a Docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image which then in turns creates the
docker container and then we are able to
push that out up to a Docker Hub and
then share that Docker Hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between Docker image
and Docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a Docker
container an image is built using a
Docker file and it stores that Docker
file in a Docker repository or a Docker
Hub and you can use Docker Hub as an
example and the image layer is a
read-only file system the docker
container is a collection of the runtime
instances of a Docker image and the
containers are created using Docker
images and they are stored in the docker
Daemon and every container is a layer is
a read write file system so you can't
replace the information you can only
append to it so while you can actually
use yaml for writing your so a question
you can be asked is instead of yaml what
can be an alternate file to build Docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use Json so if
you are comfortable working with Json
and my that is something that should be
get comfortable with is you want to be
able to use that to name your files and
it's a frame of reference Json is a
logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a JavaScript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a Docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a MySQL Docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a Docker image or pull
from an existing Docker image from a
Docker repository or Hub and then you
want to be able to then use Docker to
create a new container which has my SQL
from the existing Docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image now below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have Docker registry
Is An Open Source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing Docker
images whereas in contrast for
repositories a collection of multiple
versions of a Docker image in a registry
a user can distinguish between Docker
images with their tag names and then
finally on the the registry Docker also
has its own default registry called
Docker hub for the repository it is a
collection of multiple versions of
Docker images it is stored in a Docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own Enterprise registry so
you're going to be asked you know what
are the cloud platforms that support
Docker really you know list them all and
we have listed here Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure Google Cloud Rackspace
but you could add in their IBM bluemix
you could put in Red Hat really any of
the cloud service providers out there
today do support Docker it's just become
an industry standard so what is the
purpose of Expose and publish commands
in Docker so if we go through expose is
an instruction used in Docker file
whereas publish is used in Docker run
command for expose it is used to expose
ports within a Docker Network whereas
with Publishers can be used as side of a
Docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with published is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in Docker whereas for publish we
use the command Dash p for when we're
doing our command line used in Docker
and examples of these are expose 8080 or
with Docker we would put in all for
publish we would do the example Docker
run Dash Dash p and then
0.0.0.80 colon 80 as our command line
hello and welcome to kubernetes
interview questions now the great thing
about being a kubernetes expert is that
there is a growing market for people
wanting to hire you and you're going to
get asked a lot of questions in this
video we're going to take you through
the 13 most common questions that you
are likely to be asked in a kubernetes
interview as always if you like this
video we have the Subscribe button below
and then the like button that will
notify you of all the new videos as they
get submitted also if you have any
questions feel free to post those into
the questions below and we'll get back
to you with answers with train answer as
many questions as possible so without
any more hesitation let's jump into some
of the popular interview questions that
you're going to get asked we're going to
break up the interview questions into
three categories it's going to be
beginner intermediate and advanced the
beginner questions are really going to
cover about three quarters of the
questions that we're going to ask here
and then the intermediate and advanced
will finalize out the we'll finish out
the final quarter and and the reason is
is that quite typically most interviews
you'll be asked you know intermediate to
beginner level questions mainly beginner
level questions just so you can
demonstrate your understanding of
kubernetes and then there's always one
Advanced question that gets thrown out
just to make sure that you really do
know what you're talking about and
you've done at least one or two
kubernetes in environment as setups to
be able to validate your experience so
let's kind of jump into that first
section which is you know why is
kubernetes widely used and your answer
to this really comes into the fact that
kubernetes is widely used because of
three distinct areas one is that
kubernetes is an open source platform
that is readily available for the
management containers and allows you to
manage the deployment scaling and
management of those containers and so
the first area is that it allows you for
easy deployment of your containers the
ability to scale effectively within
kubernetes not just vertically but
horizontally for your containers and
then finally the kubernetes environment
itself was really designed to make it
easy to manage containers
um in small parts other key areas of why
kubernetes is popular is that kubernetes
is the single largest open source
project out there since its launched in
2014 is just grown in Leaps and Bounds
um around that project there is just a
huge Community both an online and
physical Community there are just a
large number of online groups that are
supporting kubernetes and allow you to
get fast access to information but in
addition to that there are also a lot of
local meetup groups that cover
specifically kubernetes whether as part
of a devops group or as part of a
dedicated kubernetes group the actual
environment itself is a really robust
way of being able to manage your
containers and containers are becoming
the most popular way of being able to
deploy cloud-based applications
kubernetes is an effective and
persistent storage environment so
kubernetes is also able to effectively
manage persistent storage whether it's
local storage as a SSD drive or a local
hard drive or whether it's cloud-based
storage and because of the way that
kubernetes architecture is redesigned
for the cloud from the ground up so it's
a great way to get started in building
out your cloud Solutions and then
finally the actual tools within
kubernetes are designed to help and
manage the health and monitoring of the
environment itself so what is Google
container engine so the Google container
engine is another open source solution
but it's designed for managing the
docker containers and clusters and so
kubernetes is a container management
solution and Docker is the most popular
container solution out there and this is
just a way of being able to bring the
two effectively with into each other so
that you can have Docker containers
manage the application and then
kubernetes manage the scale of your
applications as their vertically and
horizontally scaled across your network
so what is the difference between
kubernetes and Docker and this is
important because kubernetes and Docker
are often dropped in the same sentence
and there's a lot of people that get
confused between the two so
fundamentally kubernetes is about taking
pods which contain containers which have
applications in and deploying them at
scale across a cloud Network Docker is
the container solution itself so the
actual application itself is put into
the docker container because of this
difference kubernetes is designed for
auto scaling is highly available whereas
Docker simply isn't because it doesn't
have to worry about that within the
container itself the kubernetes
environment will check for liveness and
Readiness of the health of the entire
infrastructure whereas with Docker it's
just really going to check the services
that are coming in and out of the actual
application itself within the container
kubernetes is complicated to set up it
really is just simply complicated setup
and what you'll find is a lot of cloud
services will actually do the setup for
you whereas Docker is very easy to set
up the as you would expect with the
tolerance ratio there is high fault
tolerance River kubernetes whereas with
Dockers low filter tolerance again this
is fundamental in the two different
types of strategy that kubernetes and
Docker have they're both connected
tightly with each other but they both do
different things things so what are the
notable features of kubernetes one is
the ability to do container bands
kubernetes always knows where to place a
container within its entire network
within the pods and with its
infrastructure the services are managed
for Security Network and storage it is
self-monitoring so it goes in and is
able to check its own nodes for health
and the containers within the nodes so
it makes sure that the applications are
always running effectively you can do
the scaling effectively both vertically
and horizontally within kubernetes the
solution is open source so there's no
actual fee for the actual kubernetes
service itself and kubernetes allows for
storage orchestration what does it mean
by Storage orchestration storage
orchestration is that you're able to
access and share either local storage
such as a hard drive or SSD drive or a
cloud-based drive and my preference is
always to go with cloud-based drive
because then you're really positioning
Your solution to be a a true cloud-based
application so what are the main
advantages of kubernetes well you get
automatic rollback for changes that go
wrong the a you're able to automate a
lot of the processes that would have
been manual processes previously uh
you're able to scale the resources both
vertically and horizontally easily and
quickly and then these three areas the
rollback automating roll Bank automating
services and being able to scale
indirectly allows you to save money by
reducing the amount of time and people
working on your operations environment
so let's break out the architecture of
kubernetes so you're going to be
explaining us to explain how is
kubernetes architecture structured and
there are three key areas there's the
application layer there's kubernetes
layer and then there's the
infrastructure layer we're going to
start off with the infrastructure layer
and so the infrastructure layer is our
base layer and this is where all your
where you make your clusters for your
collections of storage and networking
resources Within kubernet and this is
where you would have if your databases
are your data stored locally on a hard
drive or in the cloud your core Network
and the VMS that you'll be building out
your infrastructure on these allow you
to group many machines together into a
single unit so that you're able to scale
up and down very easily to meet customer
demand so let's talk about the middle
layer which is the kubernetes layer now
so if we're looking at our architecture
for a kubernetes layers really broken
down for the the core operating system
the docker container environment and the
kubernetes code itself and this is where
you're able to take machines and pull
them together as a cluster so that they
work within that kubernetes system you
have a master controller within the
kubernetes that actually then we'll go
ahead and manage the schedule the
control manager the API server and then
you'll be able to Cluster all of these
kubernetes together so that they're all
working and processing as one single
unit and then finally let's look at the
application layer where you actually
have your apps and so the application
layer where you have your pool and your
services you know kubernetes will use
API to connect in and out of this layer
it's to run your applications within
containers and use instructions that are
written in yaml or Json to actually set
up those containers and you actually
have the environment running on a plan
that examines these instructions so it
keeps the entire environment healthy API
ecosystem is used to interact with the
cluster it's so you don't have to do
that by yourself so make sure that
you're referencing that the apis are
secured and connecting in and out of the
system and so you have your scheduling
control manager actually from the
kubernetes environment doing the hard
work and then the workers themselves
execute the the commands they're coming
from kubernetes so you will be asked to
kind of dig into some of the key areas
such as explain the master node and
listing its components so the masternode
is comprised of four key components
there's the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the API server
so four key Point components remember
four fingers four components and then
you're going to be asked to maybe dig
deeper into what is a cluster within
kubernetes and so a customer is really a
combination of resources such as
machines that into a single node and
then those nodes are pulled together and
work as a single cluster as a whole
kubernetes will work with that whole
cluster and then once you're actually
working with that whole cluster if a
node fails or needs to be removed
kubernetes is able to do that quickly
and effectively so let's talk a little
bit about what are the different types
of controllers in kubernetes and there
are five types of control manager you
have the node controller the service
account the token controller the
endpoint control dollar and the
replication controller and so the no
controller controls and handles the node
in the system the service account
enables access controls in the system
the token controller cleans up any
tokens for non-existent service accounts
the endpoint controller joins services
in pods to the endpoint objects and the
replication controller manages the Pod
life cycle so what is the role of the
cloud controller manager within this
environment and so the role the cloud
control manager is really to help manage
persistent storage and so persistent
storage is storage that's either local
storage to the physical machine such as
an SSD or hard drive or cloud-based
storage and this allows the storage to
be shared across the entire network what
is the role of the cube API server and
the cube scheduler so the cube API
server responsible for the establishment
communication between the kubernetes
nodes and the master components and and
it does this through the through apis
the apis ourselves or all commands that
are rest based commands and it
implements an interface which means
different tools and libraries can
communicate effectively with each other
so what is the role of the cube API
server and the cube scheduler so the
cube schedule actually does the
distribution of work across the entire
infrastructure so the actual yaml script
that you've written are executed
appropriately at the right time so
you're going to be asked to explain
persistent volumes in kubernetes so a
persistent volume is just a place where
you can store data again this can be
local data as in a hard drive local to
the physical machine or it can be
cloud-based data so what is a cubelet
and a cube proxy so a cubelete is a
service responsible for conveying
information to and from the control plan
itself the process and the qproxy itself
is responsible for maintaining the work
and the standards within the node server
in addition every node in the cluster
runs a simple Network proxy and Cube
proxy rounds request to the correct
container in that node in addition
you'll have some basic and primitive
load balancing and management of the
node from the proxy itself and there's
additional layers of management that get
done outside of the proxy but the proxy
is also there to help do some localized
load management so what is Cube CTL so
Cube CTL is your command line or
terminal window interface that allows
you to execute commands and later in
this video we'll actually go through
some of those commands
etcd is the store that configures the
details and essential values such as key
value pairs that are distributed across
your entire network it also manages the
network rules and the post-forwarding of
activity so what are the disadvantages
of kubernetes well the first is it's
really hard to install and configure and
this is why Azure and many cloud
services such as Google Cloud will
actually do the installation and
configuration of kubernetes for you a
does take a long time to get up and
running with kubernetes not so much for
the actual software but your own
experience of being able to use
kubernetes it is not simple to manage
the service you actually have to have a
lot of experience and this is why people
get paid a lot for kubernetes skills
it's a difficult environment to get up
and running and be effective in that
management again kubernetes is just not
an easy platform to learn it takes a lot
of time and effort and one of the
disadvantages is that while kubernetes
itself is free because it is an open
source project getting the people who
are skilled you to using kubernetes is
expensive all right so those were kind
of the introductory questions that you
can expect to be asked in your interview
the next set of questions are really
going to be on an intermediate and
advanced level and these are the
questions that will be thrown out you
know you can see these as being the the
trick questions which are really there
to test that you have the skill set to
be able to implement and manage
kubernetes within a company so what
happens if a master node fails what
happens if a worker node fails how would
kubernetes manage that well kubernetes
is really designed for this kind of
scenario and so you can actually look at
it and the response would be is that the
Pod itself does not get affected and
kubernetes will actually respond and fix
the uh the failed node whether it is
needs to be repaired but then needs to
be restarted or needs to be replaced so
what does a service role in kubernetes
so a service role is an abstraction for
all of the pods it provides a virtual
IEP address and allows clients to
connect to Containers running in the
pods using that virtual IP address and
the command that you would use to get
that would use some of these Cube CTL
commands it's quite a simple one it's
Cube CTL get services and you get a full
list then of all the services that are
available so how do I do a rollback in
deployment and so there's a couple of
ways you can do the rollback and the
first is if you want to see the rollout
history deployment you would write Cube
CTL rollout history deployment and then
in square brackets deployment if you
want to just restore to the previous
rollout the command would be Cube CTL
roll out undo deployment and then in
square brackets deployment and that
would take you back to the previous
deployment so what is an Ingress
controller so an Ingress controller it
really is a pod that manages that
inbound traffic and a prominent feature
that traffic is that it is secured with
an SSL termination and so what we're
going to do to now address some of the
key ways in which you can provide API
Securities on kubernetes and we have
eight of those so the first four are
implementing TL TLS for your security
the second would be API authentication
the third is to make the Cubist
protection the cubeless protected via
authorization mode equals web book
command the fourth is to monitor rbac
failures the fifth is to remove those
default service account permissions six
would be to filter egress to Cloud API
metadata apis the seventh is to use pod
security policy to restrict container
policies and protect the node and the
eighth and final is to keep the cube at
the latest version all right let's go
into some of the more advanced commands
and so the advanced questions you're
going to get are all going to be
commands that you're going to be asked
to write now my advice for you for these
questions is to make sure that you have
some of these basic commands memorized
they don't have to be perfect when
you're in the interview environment but
it's good to be able to get up to a
whiteboard and actually write out what
these commands are just so you can
actually demonstrate that you know what
the commands are the interviewer isn't
going to ask you questions on how would
you to apply kubernetes to the company
that you're being hired for because you
simply don't have that knowledge but
they do want to be able to see clearly
that you understand the commands and
terminal window instructions that will
be able to demonstrate how you would
actually go in and access some of that
information so from the first questions
you might be asked is how do you package
kubernetes applications and so you would
use the package manager within
kubernetes to be able to manage to put
and configure and deploy applications
into your cluster and so here we have
the the helm command that you would use
so what are init containers and any
container gets executed before any other
containers can run on the Pod and so you
want to be able to illustrate what's the
init instructions would look like and
here we have an example and I would
again use this example and maybe
memorize it for when you have this
question come up in your interview so
what is the difference between a config
map and a secret and these are more uh
fundamentals so a config map just has
the instructions that are clearly
available in plain text on what the cube
is supposed to do whereas the secrets
are actually encrypted and these are
like passwords and other sensitive data
that you don't want to have um easily
available these are encrypted
information that have to be decrypted to
access the content so if a node is
Tainted is there a way to schedule the
pods to that node and the answer is no
there isn't and so what you have to do
then is schedule the Pod to be fixed and
so that schedule the Pod to fix the
tainted node to allow for tolerations to
that and we have here the example code
that you would use to do that so how do
you deploy a feature with zero downtime
in kubernetes well kubernetes is
designed to be able to roll out
applications with zero downtime and here
we have four examples using the rolling
update as a strand strategy for zero
downtime deployments in kubernetes again
memorize one of these so you can
actually illustrate how you use rollout
to be able to deploy a zero downtime
solution so how do you monitor a pod
that is always running and so to do that
you would use the liveness probe to
check the health of the application
within the Pod and see whether or not
there are any failures or whether or not
the Pod itself needs to be restarted so
how do you drain traffic from pod during
a maintenance so again this is a simple
command for you to remember but to be
able to drain an application so that
it's easy for you to be able to do
maintenance on the application you would
use the cube CTL drain and then in
square brackets the node name and that
would then temporarily drain that
particular pods you can actually do
maintenance on it what you have to then
and this would probably give you bonus
points with your in an interview is then
reference the uncordant command and so
that you can uncoordinate the actual
node itself so that the Pod itself can
come back up into live um and work as a
fully functioning solution so to be able
to tie services to a podder to a set of
Parts is that you can apply labels to
the actual Parts themselves and then use
the labels as selectors to be able to
glue services to that pod and again we
have here an example of how you'd
actually do that and again this is one
of those where you can probably won't be
asked to write this out but it'd be good
to have this memorized how do you get
all pods on a node and so the following
command will actually go ahead and bring
all the pods into a kubernetes cluster
this is quite lengthy and you know maybe
you want to like talk to how this would
be done but we have the instructions on
how to do that right here the important
part is to make sure that you are when
you're talking about the node name that
you reference to whoever you're
interviewing that you would what you
would switch out to to reference the
actual nodes that you're trying to pull
together into the kubernetes cluster so
how do pods Mount NFS volumes and so in
these examples here we actually Define
the NFS server and then the Pod and how
you'd actually Mount two together and
again what you want to be able to do is
illustrate why you would use yaml and
how you'd actually then point to
specific IP addresses within your
kubernetes environment within the the
production or test environments to be
able to illustrate how you would Mount
up those NFS volumes
it's a free open source computer
software that is used to monitor systems
networks and infrastructure
nagios was initially released in 2002
and since then has become the go-to
solution for monitoring in the devops
lifecycle
in this video we have compiled the most
important nagios interview questions
that you might face in the nagios OR
devops interview
so without further Ado let's get started
so let's look at continuous monitoring
so with continuous monitoring how does
netgears help in continuous monitoring
of systems applications and service and
so this is really just a high level
question of using netgears within your
environment and you should be able to
just come back very quickly and say nag
yes allows you to help manage the
servers and check if they've been
sufficiently utilized and if there are
any task failures that need to be
addressed and so there are three areas
of utilization and risk that you want to
be able to manage this is being able to
verify the status and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and if
applications are working properly
together with our web services and apis
that are reachable so the second
question you'll be asked is how does
negus help in continuous monitoring of
systems applications and services so
it's able to do this by having the
initial negative process and scheduler
and the additional plugins that you
would use for your network connect with
the remote resources and the negative
web interface to be able to run status
checks on a predefined schedule so what
do you mean by nagius remote plugin
executor or the mpre of nine years so
mpre allows you to execute plugins on
links Unix machines that allow you to do
additional monitoring and machine
metrics such as disk usage CPU load Etc
what are the ports used by nagios for
monitoring purposes in this example
there are three and they're easy to
remember so I would memorize these three
but they're essentially ports five six
six five six six seven and five six six
eight so the there are two types of
checks within that year so you will be
asked for what is an active and passive
check in nagios so an active check and
is initiated by the nagios process and
is run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks uh results are submitted to their
years for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nagios Daemon and negus will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plugin will then
check the operational state of the host
or servers and then process the results
of the host or service check and send
out notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and I guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negos may send out notifications log
alerts Etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in Nigeria so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how many years
operate so consider this as the
configuration file that it's read by
both now us processor and the cgis so
this will allow you to be able to manage
the main configuration file that's
placed into your settings directory so
what is the netios network analyzer and
again hold out your four fingers because
there are four options here so the nagis
network analyzer R1 provides an in-depth
look at all your network traffic source
and security threats two allows system
admins together high level information
on the healthier Network Three provides
a central view of your network traffic
and bandwidth container and then four
allows you to proactive in resolving
outages abnormal behavior and threats
before they affect critical business
processes so what are the benefits of
HTTP and SSL certificate monitorings
with nag years so with HTTP certificate
monitoring it allows you to have
increased server and services and
application availability obviously very
important fast detection of network
outages and protocol failures and allows
web transaction and web service
performance monitoring the SSL
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explain
virtualization with nagios so in
response that's the first thing you
should be able to talk about is how 9
years itself can run on many different
virtualization platforms including
Microsoft Visual PC VMware Zen Amazon
ec2 et cetera Etc so just make sure you
get that right off the bad and I guess
it was able to provide capabilities
tomorrow and so much of metrics on
different platforms it allows for ensure
for quick detection of service and
application failures and has the ability
to be able to monitor against many
metrics including CPU usage memory
networking and VM status so name the
three variables that affect recursion
inheritance in nagias and it is name use
and register so name is a template name
that can be referenced in other object
definitions use specifies the name of
the template object that you want to
inherit its properties and variables
from and register indicates whether or
not the object definition should be
registered to nagios and on the right
hand side of the screen we have an
example of what that script would look
like again you may want to be able to
memorize this as it's something that you
can achieve write down and show someone
if you're going through a technical
interview so why is nagyo said to be
object r oriented and fundamentally
comes down to the object configuration
format that you can use in your object
definitions it allows you to inherit
properties from other object definitions
and this is typical object-oriented
development and is now applied for the
nagios environment so some of the
objects that you can inherit are
Services host commands and time periods
so finally explain what is State talking
in nagios and so there are really four
options here when you're talking about
State stalking so State stocking is used
for login purposes in nagios it allows
you to enable for a particular host or
service that nagos will watch over very
carefully it will lock any changes it
sees in the output of the check results
and then finally helps the analysis of
log files
Jenkins is a popular devops open source
automation server it is used to automate
the non-human part of software
development and supports continuous
integration and continuous delivery
Jenkins is a server-based system that
runs in servlet containers such as
Apache Tomcat
we have compiled the most important
Jenkins interview questions that you
might face in a Jenkins or devops
interview
so without further Ado let us get
started with Jenkins interview questions
and answers so the first question you'll
be asked about with Jenkins is explain a
Master Slave architecture of Jenkins so
the way that Jenkins is set up is that
the Jenkins Master will pull code from
your remote gate repository such as
GitHub and we'll check that repository
every time there is a code commit it
will distribute the workload of that
code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code to all of the
Jenkins slaves and then on requests the
Jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
Jenkins file and simply put a Jenkins
file as a text file that has a
definition of the Jenkins Pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit Trail for
that Pipeline and also provides a single
source of troop for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs Jenkins from the
command line is it Java Dash jar
jenkins.war Java Dash War
jenkins.jar Java dot dash jar Jenkins
jar Java Dash War
jenkins.war and the answer is a Java
Dash jar Jenkins dot wall so when
working with Jenkins you're going to be
asked what are the key Concepts and
aspects of working with a Jenkins
Pipeline and you want to really hold out
your fingers here and go through four
key areas and that is pipeline node step
and stay so pipeline refers to the use
defined model of a CD continuous
delivery pipeline node are the machines
which is which are part of that Jenkins
environment within the pipeline step app
is a single task that tells Jenkins what
to do at that particular point in time
and then finally stage defines a
conceptually distinct subset of tasks
performed through the entire Pipeline
and tasks could be build test and deploy
so which of the following file is used
to Define dependency in Maven and do we
have A build.xml B palm.xml C
dependency.xml or D version dot XML and
the answer is
palm.xml working with Jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in Jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovy script as
the domain-specific language for Jenkins
there are one or more note blocks that
are used throughout the entire Pipeline
on the left hand side you can actually
see what the actual script would look
like and the right hand side shows what
the actual declaration for each section
of that script would be the second time
of Jenkins pipeline is a declarative
Pipeline and a decarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to Define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of Jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up Jenkins to your
Jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that the question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
Jenkins from one server to another well
they're essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of Jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the thing
third is to rename an existing job by
renaming a directory so security is
fundamental to all the work that we do
within devops and Jenkins provides the
center core to all the work that gets
completed within a devops environment
there are three ways in which you can
apply security to authenticate users
effectively and when you're asked about
this question of security within Jenkins
the three responses you want to be able
to provide is a Jenkins has its own
internal database that uses secured user
data from and user credentials B is you
can use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate Jenkins users or C you can
actually configure Jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a a core plug-in within Jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot HPI plugin file into the Jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi dot pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
Jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off Jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into Jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a Jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to True which which allows for
security to be enabled if you then
change the user security setting to
false Security will be disabled allow
you to make your administrative changes
and will not be re-enabled until the
next time Jenkins is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in Jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running Jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
Jenkins at that point the second can be
after the completion of other builds so
maybe you have multiple builds in your
project that are dependent on each other
and when so many other builds have been
executed then you can have Jenkins run
you can schedule builds to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
bills of your code that illustrate the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart Jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart Jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waking for
bills to complete by using the Jenkins
URL that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the URL for your Jenkins
environment slash safe restart now with
that we have come to an end of Basics
and also the devops week by simply learn
hope the week was informative and
interesting if you have missed out on
any of the sessions then please feel
free to check them out in our official
YouTube channel the link to which is in
the description box below and if you
have any queries then please leave them
down in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries hoping to see
you again on another exciting learning
week by simply learn until next time
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe to stay tuned for more from
Simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here